wir reden viel über die spd die spd hat
zur eingangs diese von uli vielleicht
jahr 2008 er weiß noch gar nicht im
sie ja in ehren halten für die jahre die
wie alle gemerkt haben putin problem ich
auch nur ganz kurz und muss ich nur
privatpersonen geworden sie hat ein büro
deutschen bundestag und will mir also im
sie regiert hat aber das sieht natürlich
vergegenwärtigen 2008 war die
sage nur die spd und antworte ich glaube
mit neun angestellten mehr als jeder
profitiert hat von der agenda 2010 dass
nachhinein ist natürlich jeder jetzt
schwarzmeerflotte der russen noch auf
andere kanzler vor ihr also ein
auch die cdu und zwar in gestalt ihrer
schlauer ein punkt hätte ich
der krim damals stationiert und man muss
die arbeitsmarktmaßnahmen
arbeitsfähige behörde klein behörde
es wäre doch jetzt ist wäre doch jetzt
kanzler königin angela merkel die
arbeitsmarktmaßnahmen nicht sofort
sich die frage stellen ob dieser
sozusagen die auch meine rede
wohl viel zu sagen ja also man hat das
gewirkt haben das ist doch jedem klar
kanzlerin die für putin nützlicher war
konflikt wirklich vermieden hätte werden
aufschreiben kann oder ein interview
alles schon immer gewusst und 2008 hätte
das sind ökonomen klar sie als
können oder vielleicht früher
organisieren kann und sie selbst und
man dann zu einer anderen entscheidung
finanzfachmann auch als gymnasiallehrer
über die vielen jahre hinweg als der
ausgebrochen wäre sogar wenn man in den
kommen müssen im nachhinein stimmt das
viel gescholtene gerhard schröder sie
wissen das genauso und insofern aber die
zwar diese neuen leute bezahlt vom
natürlich das ist was sie gerade eben
hat nämlich
steuerzahler und sie selbst trägt 15.000
russen mit einem mit einer
ausgeführt haben eine argumentation ist
frage was auf die freundlich höflich
zunächst mal ihr die ukraine
natürlich aus meiner sicht auch richtig
transport haben eine wand stand
euro pension ungefähr im monat das ist
nato-mitgliedschaft ein nato staaten ja
deutschland basiert auf der seite nach
wäre die ukraine mitglied der nato hätte
eine gewisse verpflichtung sie steht
als euro machen die anderen araber sind
wir haben die hinterräder nachrede
putin die ukraine eben nicht angegriffen
nach wie vor im öffentlichen leben ich
märkte unter der marke lancia schäden
um
nicht also wie gesagt hinterher sind
erwarte von angela merkel mal eine
so aber jetzt ist das alles vergossene
nicht über die bilanz von schröder und
geschädigt dadurch dass sie bei der bau
merkel der rede über die frage wer
einfach schlauer ich glaube nicht dass
milch was mir viel wichtiger wäre wäre
erklärung und einen akt der selbstkritik
der beim bau der nord-stream-pipeline 2
das funktioniert hätte aber da ich
barceló er geholfen hat und wer für ihn
die frage was lernen wir eigentlich nach
glaube mein letzter satz meinerseits man
nützlicher war gerhard schröder war nach
also ich würde mir tatsächlich auch
vorne raus weil das was jetzt mit
kann daraus lernen dass
wünschen dass wir mal etwas von angela
dem ende seiner kanzlerschaft 2005 nicht
zunächst mal die europäischen
russland passiert gebe ich ihnen brief
unklare verhältnisse für einen staat
merkel zu der gesamten geschichte hören
widerstände bei seite geräumt hat und im
mehr als ein aushängeschild der
und siegel ist in den nächsten fünf bis
also wenn man ihnen eine grauzone stößt
man muss aber glaube ich schon
sommer vergangenen jahres auch noch die
russischen energiekonzerne er saß bei
zehn jahren eine frage auch im
das war die ukraine wo man nicht wusste
feststellen es gibt schon einmal ein
amerikanischen sanktionspläne
verhältnis zu china und da haben wir
unterschied zwischen gerhard schröder
der gazprom bei den pipeline
wozu gehört überhaupt gehört die zu
zerschlagen hat damit war klar wenn
europa zum besten oder ist sie nach wie
doch genau die gleichen themen nord
und angela merkel gerhard schröder ist
tochtergesellschaften und bei rosneft in
nicht der krieg gekommen wäre die
stream 2 von russland ist die
vor auf moskau orientiert die ost
auf der payroll von putin lobby irrt
pipeline wird zu ende gebaut deutschland
seidenstraße der chinesen
ukraine war richtung moskau in die
den aufsichtsorganen aber er hatte ja
andere hälfte war richtung europa
oder europa werden noch abhängiger
wirklich in einer fast unverschämten art
keine keine politischen
einfluss überall auf der welt und von
orientiert und sie gehörte weder zur eu
gewesen von russischem gas punkt 1.2
eingriffsmöglichkeiten er war nicht mehr
und weise in den vergangenen jahren für
daher würde ich mir wünschen dass sich
und zur nato und das ist 2008 an gericht
kanzler während angela merkel kanzlerin
die deutsche politik in ihrer und auch
der
dieses thema ist ja jetzt dann über
war und mit ihrer mit ihren politischen
die wirtschaft im übrigen in ihrem
politikfeld zeit dahin macht er so
frühere polnische eu ratspräsident
istanbul nach moskau geflogen und wollte
verhältnis zu china jetzt mal legt was
fähigkeiten in die weltpolitik
schrecklich weil in einem solchen
das nicht mal informieren habe ich
eingegriffen hat um putin zu helfen
machtvakuum kann man eingreifen und zwar
können wir denn da so machen dass wir
donald tusk hat das als ihren größten
einmal
eine frage die mir ganz klar wer hat uns
nicht in zehn jahren in der situation
einmal in der hinsicht dass sie die die
auch militärisch und das ist passiert
fehler bezeichnet die förderung der
sind wir alle wieder sagen ach butt
und ich will ja nicht der angela merkel
denn das bessere deutschland
pipeline ich finde es gibt noch vielen
hätte man nicht vor zehn jahren andere
nord stream 2 durchgesetzt hat wie sie
hinterlassen weil sie haben gerade
entgegen halten ja ich habe auch nicht
im caravan friedrich merz damit ich höre
größeren fehler 2008 beim nato gipfel in
gerhard schröder angesprochen also dem
wegen des ukraine kriegs gestopft werden
ihn nicht ich sehe nicht mit genau
gedacht dass putin den fehler macht
sollten wie er den vorwurf machen wann
dieser aussage ständiger friedrich merz
musste und zweitens weil sie die
bukarest hat angela merkel dafür gesorgt
finde ich einen solchen krieg
stand deutschland dann besser da nach
schon seit vier jahren seit er
anzuzetteln aber soll sie doch mal uns
der kanzlerschaft von gerhard schröder
aufnahme der ukraine die nato verhindert
dass die ukraine nicht in das bündnis
mal erklären wie sie damals die
oder nach angela merkel naja also wenn
öffentlich wieder auftritt sie können
hat das waren einschneidende
situation eingeschätzt hat warum sie so
aufgenommen wird george bush der
entscheidungen solche einschneidenden
sich seine reden anschauen war einer der
ich mir beispielsweise die
arbeitslosenzahlen wenn ich mir die
entschieden hat gegen george bush
amerikanische präsident wollte das
ersten deutschen politiker die das thema
entscheidungen zugunsten von putin hat
wirtschaftszahlen anschaue dann ganz
damals unbedingt und angela merkel hat
klar jetzt und nicht eben vor 16 jahren
china überhaupt wieder angesprochen
schröder nie getroffen konnte er gar
eisern dagegen gestanden hat es
nicht er war aus dem geschäft stimmt
als gerhard schröder dann sozusagen
haben und immer wieder darauf
verhindert in ihrem schlepptau der
abgegeben hat aber am schluss ist
aber der ukrainische botschafter namik
hingewiesen hat wie sich dieser staat
französische präsident sarkozy man
hat mir mal 2009/10 schon gesagt hat
sozusagen als zehn jahren diese das ist
entwickelt er natürlich auch aus seiner
sich nach dem bundestag gearbeitet habe
stelle sich vor die ukraine wäre 2008
wirtschaftlichen expertise aus sich auch
er hat so angst dass sie geht denn in
ihrer unwürdig
ganz genau anschaut was sie denn sagt
aufgenommen worden es hätte die invasion
dem jahr an dass in dem sie ihr amt
sie ist wie putin der sagt auch genau
verlässt wird er angreifen und genau das
sind weiterhin die arbeit einmal jeder
russlands auf der krim nicht gegeben es
ist passiert dass ich dem nicht
das was er machen will und diese und die
zustimmen wie gesagt auch mal ein
hätte auch die
chinesen sagen dass im grunde genommen
argument dagegen was man beim nato
bei ist doch der wahnsinn er kann man
sagen das unterwandern der ost ukraine
die letzten 200 jahren fehler der
gipfel in bukarest
geschichte waren weil man keine
durch russische truppen in den
weltmacht mir bleiben noch ein jahr bei
2008 wo und was habe ich jetzt nicht
vergangenen jahren nicht gegeben ganz zu
der these von new yorks dass merkel
schweigen vom jetzigen krieg dann
okay
putin mehr genutzt hat als schröder und
russland hätte sich immer mit der nato
deine these ist ja ganz klar dass frau
es wurde auch gerade gesagt dass merkel
angelegt also das hat verheerende
jetzt abgetaucht ist oder gerade
merkel die ukraine also dass sie in die
trotzdem mitarbeiter wähler als
wirkungen gehabt und ich frage mich wann
un aufgenommen werden müssen 2008 in die
kommunikationsprofi ist merkel
eigentlich frau merkel mal dazu stellung
nato in die nato aufgenommen werden
abgetaucht was können wir denn als
erhalten werden müssen sowie sehen denn
nehmen will zu ihrer eigenen position
abschlussfrage zu dieser these von der
kanzlerin erwarten das müssen wir da
sie ist abgetaucht sie ist aber keine
fragen im büro die gemeinde kann sich ja
mal nachfragen oder hat tut
wahrscheinlich einmal wie schon gesagt
wir haben außer zwei glaube ich sehr
dürren statements bisher nichts gehört